Road Hog is one of overwatch's most
iconic characters but for years he's had
an identity crisis despite being a tank
he actually offers very little to
support his teammates and even after a
highly anticipated rework things haven't
really changed so the question is can
roadhog be saved or is he just a lost
[Music]
cause before we start talking about we
need to thank Rog for sponsoring today's
video here's Demitri to talk all about
their extended Black Friday deal all
right so before we get into the video
just a quick heads up that this year our
friends over at Rog are having a banger
Black Friday sale only on Amazon we
actually partnered with Rog For an
upcoming crack that you have to check
out Colton and I got to build a tricked
out PC to test out rog's brand new
state-of-the-art
540 HZ monitor now that thing is a
monster but let me let me tell you rog's
300 HZ stxs XG 27 aqm is also very
Beastly so if you're in the market for a
gorgeous top-of-the-line 1440p display
with a fast response IPS panel that
produces eyw wateringly vibrant colors
make sure you head over to Amazon to
check out this exclusive 15% off Black
Friday sale it is a sick monitor for an
even sicker price so be sure to check it
out now back to the video all right so
over the last two weeks we got to
experience roadhog's new rework and
although we don't know how it plays at
the esport level since it's currently
dead it does feel a bit underwhelming
but if you've only been tangentially
following OverWatch over the last few
years you might be wondering what the
hell's wrong with roadhog I love that
big guy well to answer that we need to
go all the way back to the beginning
when OverWatch first came out Road Hog
was an instant classic for starters he
was a Hook character in an FPS game he
was directly inspired by The Game's MOA
influences but besides his massive hook
hog was one of the more self-sustaining
heroes in the game he could heal himself
did a solid amount of damage and didn't
have to worry about any of those support
related skills he was basically a DPS
hero with more health for any of those
players who didn't want to do any of
that team that made him a pretty
damn good choice for open q and wasn't a
terrible one for roll either sure there
were more Dynamic off tanks you could
choose but it was nice knowing you had a
teammate that could easily One-Shot
those squishies you see the core of hog
was his One-Shot combo land a hook and
Bam
[Music]
now there has been a long long
conversation about one shots in
OverWatch sure it's satisfying but
people generally agree it's not always
great for the game with some even going
so far as to criticize Hanzo and Widow
partially for that reason Hog's combo
was nerfed by adding aele after the hook
and shot things got harder for your boy
when Anna came out her nade was brutal
against hog since it basically removed
his ability to heal himself and it
pretty much stayed like this until
OverWatch 2 came out along with KIRO
since she could counter it with her own
Cleanse This allowed hog to do his combo
in peace and the two quickly became
pretty meta in this new 5v5 environment
with only one tank hog could easily get
rid of these squishy support and DPS
Heroes since they're generally wasn't as
much CC in the game anymore he didn't
have to worry about pesky Shields
blocking his hook but this made him very
annoying to play against I mean the most
nontank tank was now dominating the game
and this forced blizzard to rethink
their 5v5 situation so they made a
difficult decision to completely get rid
of his One-Shot combo this was Hog's
absolute worst state and it sparked a
lot of conversations about actually
giving the guy a proper rework and then
after half a year it finally happened
for starters hog now has the ability Pig
Pen a disrupt that you know actually
provides value to the rest of the team
next to that hog can now Vape to his
heart's content meaning that his heel is
no longer a cool down but on a resource
meter so so if you get hit with
something like Anna's nade you just have
to wait a second instead of through an
entire cool down this greatly improves
his survivability which was absolutely
needed unfortunately it just doesn't
feel like enough of a change pig pen is
easily destroyed has a long ass cooldown
and hog still doesn't have any damage
mitigation for his teammates all he can
do is heal himself and survive making
him like a walking alt battery he's a
big fighter so enemies just have to poke
him to build their alt charges on top of
that he still has no Mobility so there's
zero opportunity for him to disrupt or
dive the enemy team like doomfist or
ballan so he doesn't really feel like a
tank outside of the fact that he's just
an absolute unit a tank is meant to
create space mitigate damage and protect
or peel for your teammates hog
technically can do these things just
worse than every other tank in the game
as a result hog was almost immediately
buffed again and there are some
improvements to his numbers but we can
run into the same issue where he
basically just becomes a glorified DPS
again which is where we get to the issue
of hogs bigger identity crisis one
problem that blizzard has always had
with reworks is how do we change a hero
without removing what makes them them
everyone knows that roadhog is the guy
with the hook you remove that and he's
not Road Hog anymore mind you I don't
think the hook is the problem but you
get my point his abilities as well as
who he is as a character are why people
gravitated towards him in the first
place lizzard doesn't want to give that
up it's a rework of Hog's been in the
game for seven years we don't want to
piss off the hog play is by removing
elements of his kit although they have
removed alternate fire but they're not
going to mess with Hulk I can see what
they've done and I think they've
succeeded but the problem is I don't
think this hog really feels any
different this is probably the reason
Road Hog's rework is so underwhelming
blizzard is scared to make drastic
changes to his actual kit for the
longest time hog was either completely
busted or absolute trash and when he's
good no one's having fun so blizzard is
forced to belittle him to a dumpster
pick but Road Hog struggles go Way
Beyond on him and just shine a light on
OverWatch 2's bigger issue with tanks
because there's only one tank
counterpicks are more apparent than ever
every single tank in the game can be
countered in a direct way for example
you pick Ry so they choose orisa to
counter then you switch to zarya which
counters orisa but then they just choose
Ryan again that counters zarya and it
just goes on forever unless you play in
my rank where people are seemingly
unaware or unwilling to switch their
Heroes mid round Road Hog just gets the
most Spotlight right now because he
seems to have the most counters which is
where we get to the potential paths and
questions for blizzard now outside of
continuing to buff him as a Band-Aid
solution they can give him another
rework if blizzard wants to admit they
have a problem on their hands but what
would that look like and would fans be
okay with fundamental changes to his kit
it's either that or we go back to 6v6
make him a DPS hero or just live with
the fact that some heroes are just never
really going to fit
in I will say they did this to to chanka
cuz he was like the shittiest character
in Rainbow Six but he was so iconic
because he was shitty like there's the
Lord to chanka memes big helmet big gun
and the whole thing was his big gun and
they actually just got rid of it and
gave him a grenade launcher instead and
it's funny because he he was so bad but
then he became a little broken after
that because he could you know remove so
much space with the grenade launcher but
uh yeah I mean it worked I guess for him
but can they do the same with Road Hog I
don't know